on May 21 2023 Ray Stevenson died at the
age of 58. the news rocked the
entertainment industry in celebration of
the actor's career in life let's take a
look back at the late Ray Stevenson
when the shocking news of Ray
Stevenson's death was announced many of
his co-stars and friends took to social
media or they posted heartfelt tributes
to the northern Irish actor on Instagram
Ahsoka Star Rosario Dawson shared
several photos of her with Stevenson on
set writing a giant of a man stunned and
reeling from this tragic devastating
news Gone Too Soon from this world at a
loss for words just wanted to mark this
moment and share your ever ready and
present smile love you forever Stevenson
was a complex and unconventional action
hero whose path to movie and TV starred
almost anything but ordinary that being
said he always exhibited enthusiasm and
appreciation for his work the process
and what he ultimately achieved and he
was quick to share the credit with
everyone in front of the camera and
behind the scenes who'd been a part of
his acting Journey
ask any actor who their favorite
performer is and there will usually be
several answers don't be surprised
though if more than half the responses
feature the names of acclaimed Leading
Men like Marlon Brando Clark Gable and
Paul Newman as an actor Cut From a
Different Cloth Ray Stevenson looked at
a different set of thespians as
inspiration telling backstage it was the
likes of Lee Marvin Gene Hackman never a
bad performance and brave and fearless
within that caliber it was never the
young hot leading man it was men who I
could identify with while impressed by
Marvin and Hackman's work the actor
stressed that it was a combination of
other elements which helped these actors
Shine On Screen Stevenson believed
actors Excel as performers when the
right creative talent in other parts of
the production is supportive and
provides the necessary tools for success
to quote the horrid and cheesy corporate
approved term Teamwork Makes the Dream
Work
from a notorious swashbuckling
historical pirate to Marvel's most
infamous gun toning vigilante Ray
Stevenson brought a Litany of characters
to life in his storied career either you
are unkillable
a way overdue however like most actors
he had a white whale the dream part he
chased but never quite caught in a 2008
collider interview Stevenson admitted
his love for a certain Shakespearean
play saying I've always been intrigued
by coriolanus it's potentially one of
the most potent and revealing scripts I
love the play I'd love to do that as a
movie One Day a film adaptation of Corey
elanus did arrive in 2011. Ray finds
directed produced and starred in the
movie that received near Universal
Acclaim unfortunately Stevenson wasn't a
part of the Blockbuster cast which
included the likes of Gerard Butler
Vanessa Redgrave Jessica Chastain and
Brian Cox
Ray Stevenson's most punishing role was
in Lexi Alexander's Punisher war zone
released in 2008 this reboot boasts
blood guts and more R-rated violence
than the average superhero movie
Stevenson dazzles as Frank Castle
embodying the Vigilante from the brutal
Punisher comic book series
I see you anywhere near hell
I'll kick your ass up unfortunately
Punisher Warzone either lit up the box
office nor inspired critics to get skull
tattoos on their biceps but despite the
film's underwhelming financial and
critical performance it eventually
became a cult classic in a chat with
Stevenson for the action Elite writer
David J Moore expressed this dismay that
the actor never had a chance to return
to the role of Castle Stevenson agreed
saying so was I write in and tell them
that I wouldn't heartbeat go back I love
the storyline in the comic books that it
was based on it could definitely do with
the sequel sadly this never happened as
Netflix rebooted Punisher as a series
with Walking Dead Star John Bernthal as
a titular character
the Marvel Cinematic Universe or MCU
kickstarted in May 2008 with the release
of John favreau's Iron Man while not
considered a part of the official MCU
Punisher Warzone arrived that December
considering Frank Castle's significance
in the greater Marvel Universe Ray
Stevenson found himself in an odd
situation where his character eventually
be incorporated into the MCU or would he
be cast in a different role in the
franchise the latter seemed highly
unlikely until Kenneth branagh's 2011
movie Thor in which Stevenson debuted as
volstag a member of asgard's Warriors 3
team in an interview with the AV club
Stevenson expressed surprise at the way
events unfolded saying what a great
privilege for Marvel because they have
kind of an Unwritten rule that once you
play one of their major protagonists or
characters in order to maintain a
certain degree of Integrity for Their
audience you don't get to do it again
well not a major role like The Punisher
of volstag appears in the first three
Thor films played by Stevenson each time
as one of the most popular TV shows of
all time HBO's Game of Thrones changed
the lives of its cast members making
them household names but no one
predicted the Epic Fantasy series is
game-changing Success when it first
began production consequently many
actors turned down roles on the show and
Ray Stevenson was one of them in 2015
Stevenson revealed to movie.com that he
had the opportunity to join the Game of
Thrones cast but turned it down
admitting the show was already too far
down the line for me I would rather have
been involved in the growth of a show
Even though everyone gets bumped off
left right and Center Stevenson didn't
disclose the role he was offered so as
not to take away from the actor who
ultimately played the part he did say it
would have kept him busy from anywhere
from four to six months but he'd already
agreed to play Blackbeard on Starz Black
Sails
and Showbiz actors and directors receive
all the praise when action scenes Go
full throttle however stunt performers
are the unheralded heroes of Cinema it's
the stunt doubles who perform the
death-defying dangerous sequences and
make a movie and its actors look good
for the audience Stevenson made a lot of
action films and worked with many stunt
Specialists across his various projects
speaking to coming soon.net he praised
the Daredevils for putting their bodies
on the line singling out Rob Mars who
doubled for him in several movies
Stevenson also discussed the process of
working with the stunt doubles peeling
back the curtain of movie Magic to
explain how the transition between actor
and double occurs explained when you
have a stunt man and this is his
discipline you go right up to the stunt
itself and then act during the stun so
you have this overlap and I involved
them in my process the northern Irish
porn star expressed a high level of
respect for what stunt teams do adding
that he developed personal friendships
with many of them over the years
John M Chu's GI Joe retaliation hit the
big screen in 2013. while build is the
sequel to 2009's GI Joe the Rise of
Cobra the film largely focuses on a new
group of Heroes led by Dwayne Johnson's
roadblock in the opposite corner stands
Ray Stevenson as firefly an explosive
villain who works with the Sinister
Cobra making more things go boom by 9am
and most people do all day naturally is
it two big men on the film roadblock and
Firefly eventually battle each other in
a Clash of the Titans during the filming
of GI Joe retaliation and an encounter
between Stevenson and Johnson left one
of them a bloody mess in an interview
with the Daily Record Stevenson recalled
the worst moment was when we filmed the
first big fight a spun round and
accidentally caught him right across the
bridge of his nose I drew blood and I
was worried but Dwayne just Shrugged it
off he was great about it and just said
these things happen Stevenson added how
the intensity and physicality of their
action scenes resulted in numerous
bruises throughout production and
admitted that Johnson ended up popping
him on the nose as well in the world of
pro wrestling that's referred to as a
receipt
due to his height and rugged good looks
Rey Stevenson was often cast as
physically formidable characters and
mostly action-centric Productions the
fact that so many fans still consider
him the quintessential version of The
Punisher as evidence of his powerful
reputation as an on-screen tough guy
aren't you quite vicious my dear yeah
Stevenson surprised viewers with his
work in different genres when the
opportunity arose for example he
received praise for his turn as Roger
Wesley and Adam McKay's cop comedy the
other guys which also starred Will
Ferrell and Mark Wahlberg speaking with
the AV club Stevenson gushed about the
experience of working with comedians
like barrel and revealed that McKay
called him a few days before cameras
started to roll to suggest his character
speak with an Australian accent the
actor obliged Stevenson enjoyed the
opportunity to exercise his sense of
humor saying I love doing comedy I
always maintain that there's humor in
everything
Ray Stevenson's journey to becoming an
actor was the furthest thing from
conventional he was already 25 when he
realized it was something he wanted to
pursue eventually graduating from the
Bristol Old Vic theater school at 29. a
notable Talent he worked his way up the
ranks achieving mainstream recognition
thanks to his role as dagina in 2004's
King Arthur his big breakthrough came a
year later when he was cast in the lead
role of Titus pulo in the HBO limited
series Rome from there his career took
off and the film offers flooded in
surprisingly Stevenson didn't become a
member of The Screen Actors Guild
American Federation of television and
radio artists or sag-aftra until later
in his acting career speaking to
Backstage Stevenson revealed how Rome
helped him earn the coveted Union card
saying over the course of two seasons I
created quite a bit of interest and that
gave me my representation in the states
and Ergo started my movie career at 44
which is almost unheard of it's
remarkable to consider how Stevenson
worked on a blockbuster like King Arthur
without being a part of the Union
throughout his career Ray Stevenson
shared the screen with numerous big-name
Stars including Dwayne Johnson Clive
Owen and Chris Hemsworth this is the
case in most lines of work co-workers
end up following each other on social
media occasionally interacting but also
getting hard blocks if they ratch you
out to the boss in 2015 up rocks asked
Stevenson who his favorite person to
follow online was the actor replied a
Japanese actor I worked with on Thor
asano taranobu he's involved in three or
four rock bands has his own online
fashion brand and includes photos of his
latest looks from whatever projects he's
working on and he posts sketch cartoons
which are great in 2011's Thor asano
portrayed the part of Hogan one of the
Warriors Three and he returned to the
role for the next two sequels the
Japanese actor also appeared as Lord
Kira in 2013's 47 Ronin and the God of
Thunder Raiden in 2021's Mortal Kombat
movie
from Titus pulo in Rome to Danny Green
and Kill the Irishman and Blackbeard and
Black Sails Ray Stevenson showed an act
for portraying historical figures on
screen as a result the industry and
audiences Associated him with period
pieces and he appeared to gravitate
toward those types of projects more than
others in an interview with geeks
worldwide Stevenson confessed I consider
myself a historical nerd and clearly see
the correlation between these historical
figures and the massive changes that the
world was undergoing with the spread of
civilization and the reach of England in
the same interview the actor also
revealed how he believed history had
been distorted by sensationalism such as
the pamphlets and stories of pirates
like Blackbeard it actually seems to
have been a fairly intelligent man a
good leader a bold dangerous pirate
however as an actor researching a role
he would seek out the kernels of Truth
in each account and then try to look at
the story from his character's unique
perspective coupled with the demands of
the script one of Stevenson's last
completed films before he died was a
historical drama Gateway to the West
which centers on real life events in
which the Mongolian Army invaded Hungary
Ray Stevenson achieved a unique
distinction in the Star Wars Universe by
portraying two different characters if
car Saxon could see you now
I know right the actor voiced gar Saxon
in the animated shows Star Wars the
Clone Wars and Star Wars Rebels while
also playing balance skull in the live
action Ahsoka series the latter sees
Stevenson living every Fan's biggest
dream of wielding a lightsaber and going
toe-to-toe with Rosario Dawson's Ahsoka
Tano Stevenson recognized the magnitude
and importance of stepping into the
Beloved Star Wars franchise speaking to
Entertainment Weekly he revealed the
intense preparation and dedication that
went into his portrayal of Balin while
praising the environment and hard work
that his collaborators put into making
the Disney plus series come to life on a
personal level Stevenson couldn't help
but get caught up in the moments when he
picked up a lightsaber for the first
time he confided to Entertainment Weekly
I must admit the first time you turn a
lightsaber on you make the noise and
then you're like oh I'm so sorry
everybody does that but you just can't
help it
even after he established himself in
Blockbuster Stevenson occasionally
popped up in unexpected films one of his
more out of the blue roles came in
2018's action film accident Man based on
the comic written by Pat Mills and Tony
Skinner and illustrated by a variety of
artists the film star Scott Adkins as
Mike Fallon an assassin who possesses
the ability to make his hits look like
accidents
never get angry
never get involved
and most importantly never get cold
Stevenson plays Fallon's mentor and
Father Figure big Ray Adkins and Stevens
reprise their parts for the 2022 sequel
accident Man hitman's Holiday Adkins who
is also the producer and co-writer of
the films revealed to the Hollywood news
that the role of big Ray was conceived
with Stevenson in mind saying he was
always on the list and he was the first
guy we went out to and the first guy we
got that was a great coup we need
someone who is a great actor and someone
who can sign on and help us Finance the
movie so for those who watched and
enjoyed the accident Man franchise uo
Stevenson a debt of gratitude for adding
his star power to the project
thanks to his versatility as an actor
and desire to spread his wings Ray
Stevenson appeared in everything from
historical pieces to big budget
Blockbusters this afforded him the
opportunity to Star alongside a wealth
of extraordinary Talent such as Anthony
Hopkins and Rene Russo and Thor Denzel
Washington and Gary Oldman in the Book
of Eli and Samuel L Jackson in big game
during the Press junket for big games
Stevenson revealed to topless robot that
he didn't get overalled by the stars
with whom he shared the screen no matter
how famous they were he found them to be
professionals like him were there to
serve the movie not their egos he went
on to say it just appears to be such a
great warm cuddly teddy bear feeling is
the fact that the bigger they are the
more open and giving and consummately
professional actors are and there's
fearlessness Stevenson explained that in
his experience a more experienced actors
weren't afraid to change things up in
the middle of scenes to figure out what
worked best for the film more
importantly they never tried to outshine
or upstage others choosing to be
collaborators with their focus always
remaining on the best way to elevate the
film in question
although there was no direct sequel to
Lexi Alexander's Punisher war zone Ray
Stevenson did get another chance at
running among his Frank Castle albeit in
a more family-friendly manner he lent
his voice to the animated version of The
Punisher that appears in the Superhero
Squad Show where nothing but white blood
cells hunting the infection called crime
a sickness that sneaks in through the
cracks he voices the character in the
same gritty way he played him in the
live action movie leaving the other more
fun-loving Heroes shocked at how intense
he is undoubtedly Stevenson's straight
delivery adds to the comedic effect of
his scenes as he becomes almost but not
quite to parody of Marvel's edgy
anti-hero and his bloodlust for
vengeance speaking about the role to the
AV club Stevenson opened up more about
the experience saying it was strange I
went up to a studio somewhere in LA and
voiced over all these lines I haven't
even seen it but yeah apparently it's
out there in the wonderful world while
he may not have seen the fruits of his
labor he jumped at the opportunity to
play The Punisher again as a result of
the experience Stevenson admitted to a
keen interest in doing more voice acting
he'd done a bit of it in London when he
was a young actor however he knew that
timing would be tough to work out with
his busy movie and television career
when actors are asked about their
favorite performance I'll often tell the
interviewer it's their current one much
the same way a musician always says
their new song or album is their best
work ever but Ray Stevenson decided on a
different approach when he spoke to
journalist Arthur K during the Press
tour for black sales instead of
declaring the pirate series to be his
greatest accomplishment to date
Stevenson cited Rome not only because it
was a project that elevated him to super
stardom but for personal reasons as well
Stevenson recalled it has to be Rome
that was one of the major major periods
of my life it turned my life around I
found my partner who was my landlady
Stevenson joked about how Elizabeth
caracia raised his rent even after they
became a couple while telling the story
about how his work on the series LED to
them living together having three
children and a dog he also explained
that while he was working on Rome he
learned to look in acting from an
entirely New Perspective instead of
second guessing himself or trying too
hard to remember what was next he
shifted his mindset and focus completely
on what was in front of him in his
character in that moment this changed
the way he approached his work from
there on out
in season 7 of Dexter Ray Stevenson
turns in a memorable performance as the
mobster Isaac Circo who Wants Revenge on
Dexter Morgan for killing his lover
Victor Boscov I run one of the biggest
crime syndicates in the Caucasus who is
Dexter Morgan it's a very different kind
of role from any he'd played before
which is exactly the reason the actor
agreed to do it in an interview with
Yahoo Stevenson talked about receiving a
call from Dexter producer and writer
Scott buck with whom he'd worked on Rome
Buck explained how the Circo character
would fit into the overall Arc of the
show as well as his underlying
motivations all of which fascinated
Stevenson Stevenson went on to explain
Circo is a Cold Stone mobster a killer
with a secret but he's basically a man
whose heart has been ripped out of his
body Stevenson added how Circo gave up
everything including ultimately his life
in his quest for vengeance because he
loved boskov with all his heart
considering Ray Stevenson's affinity for
historical dramas was anyone really
surprised when he was eventually cast as
a Wandering sailor of Terror and Vikings
he appears in 11 episodes of Viking
season six of course Stevenson possessed
some prior relevant experience of sorts
I mean portrayed a space fight game in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe however as
Stevenson revealed to journalist Matt J
porn while discussing his work in Thor
he had a closer connection to the world
of Vikings and most people may realize
Stevenson explained I had my formative
years in the northeast of England a
place littered with Vikings and Norse
mythology indeed my father would often
tell me that the derivative of my
surname Stevenson was in fact Svenson a
final Viking name
many actors love to talk about how
acting is a calling something more than
a profession and how they do it for
artistic value and spiritual
satisfaction you get to go to work and
you're living as an actor
what else would you want then there are
others who in addition to the passion
they feel for the process admit that
they don't hate the fame side of the job
they can be open about enjoying the
glitz and glamor of it all as well as
the many perks of stardom such as seeing
action figures based on the characters
they betrayed Ray Stevenson was one of
those and he confessed to having a very
particular goal for his career in an
interview with Bill during the Press
tour for the transporter refueled
Stevenson revealed it was a dream of
mine one day to have an action figure he
couldn't understand how anyone wouldn't
be excited about the idea while
expressing his delights at having not
one but three action figures out in the
world the actor joked that he couldn't
get too carried away with himself though
because his children brought him back
down to earth in fact his kids had
ripped the heads off his action figures
and one of them even replaced his dad's
head with a Lego one while Stevenson
didn't say which figure his child
recapitated he had a good laugh about
the whole thing
Ray Stevenson's death deeply affected
his former co-stars especially his
fellow Ahsoka castmates since the Disney
plus series was one of his final
projects before his passing in fact
Ahsoka even includes a tribute to
Stevenson in the closing credits of the
first episode part 1 master and
Apprentice in an interview with people
Rosario Dawson remembered Stevenson and
his powerful performances balance skull
but she also took the time to praise him
as a special and kind human being
recalling he'd have these crystals that
had all these different meanings from
where you know he felt like spiritually
where he came from and what he wanted to
be resonating and we'd sit and have
these conversations about the divine
feminine it's Austin went on to say that
he was a fascinating and thoughtful
individual to talk to as he loved to
discuss philosophy in his family